- Do you use a fake Starbucks name?
- I do not actually.
- Why, what's your name?
- Zack.
So, it's pretty easy.
- Oh, my God!
That's my fake Starbucks name!
Is that really your fake Starbucks name?
- No.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, my name is Amal,
and I make videos at Buzzfeed.
Now, I know what you're thinking.
That girl has a weird name.
She probably uses a fake name
when she goes to Starbucks.
I don't.
But some of you know the drill.
You get in line,
about to order your favorite drink,
and you pull out your trusty fake name.
You know, the classics.
John, Carl, or my personal favorite,
Gertrude.
Today, we'll see what your
favorite Buzzfeeders use
as their fake names when
they go to Starbucks.
All to avoid social interaction.
Let's go!
What's your fake name?
- K.
- And what's your real name?
- Kuwilileni.
K because if I ever
tried to say Kuwilileni,
they would just look at
me with their mouth agape
like who?
What?
Where?
- My fake name is Horchata Jose.
My real name is Sergio.
- My fake name is David.
- And what's your real name?
- Armand.
My real name is on my credit card,
and nobody has been like, hey!
This doesn't match.
- Well, you're now exposed, so...
- Oh, c'mon!
- If I wanna have, like fun,
I'll use like Axel Foley
or like Theo Huxtable.
- You seem like a Theo to me.
- My fake name is Kelly.
- And what's your real name?
- Kirby, like the video game.
The pink, little pink ball.
- Okay, what's your fake name?
- Lauren.
- And what's your real name?
- My real name is Selorm.
My name is actually supposed
to be pronounced, "sellum".
- So, your real name is your fake name?
Ken, do you have a fake name
when you go to Starbucks?
- My fake name is actually Ken.
(dramatic gong)
So, I moved to the states
when I was 12 or 13,
and I still went by my
real name which is Kyohei.
- Well, thanks for lying to
me for all these years, Ken.
- I've only known you for
three months, but okay.
(record scratching)
- What's your fake name?
- Bob.
(both laughing)
My real name is Onyinyechukwu.
- So, don't take this the wrong way,
but you're not giving me Bob vibes.
- They know I'm not a Bob, but it's like,
it's an understanding.
They appreciate that I'm
not wasting their time.
They're not wasting my time.
- I will give any J name.
I'll say John, Jamiroquai,
Jacob, or JoMariePayton
as one word just to see.
My real name is Jarrett.
And they've spelled it
so wrong, so many times
that I started a hashtag on my Instagram.
- What's your fake name?
- Dilly Dilly.
- And your real name?
- Danny Rosenberg.
- So, instead of making
it easier for them,
you're actually making it harder for them.
- A little bit.
I like to spice up their day.
You know, they have to say a lot of names.
So, yelling out, Dilly Dilly,
is kind of, I don't know...
- Well, there you have it folks.
The good.
The bad.
And the awkward.
Do you use a fake name at Starbucks?
Let us know.
I'm gonna get some coffee.
How does it feel like to
be a fake Starbucks name?
- Oh, Zack is a popular name?
- I mean, sure.
- You know?
I kinda like that actually.
People are like trying to be me.
Trying to use my name.
(metallic screeching and squeaking)